no question that they have the feds low
in my mind anyways no question that low
interest rates have exacerbated the in
cut the wealth gap between the poor and
the rich because the rich have assets
and that's what's being hyped here
because of low interest rates whether
they own stocks are they own real estate
or whatever the case may be and long
term that's a very big problem for this
country and you don't solve the problem
as the populace would argue by taking
things away from the rich you solve the
problem by giving opportunity to
everybody and by creating jobs and some
of these things I think some of the
policies are misguided I for example am
not in favor have never been in favor of
raising the minimum wage I think you
should raise the income tax credit which
does the same thing for the same people
but it spreads the burden across all the
taxpayers rather than just a small
number of business people who would if
his inclination would be to cut back
employment Earned Income Tax Credit
doesn't get anybody to cut back it gets
them to hire more people I'd say these
data points take out sighs importance at
a moment in time when we look kind of
Custis as to which way money policy is
going to go and so since it since the
feds activity is data dependent the next
data point takes an outsized takes an
outside importance and that's just
that's just what that's just the the way
it is